Musique grave
...
Chant religieux
-A quoi pense-t-il,
Charles de Gaulle,
en regardant passer le cercueil
de Winston Churchill
à quelques mètres de lui,
le jour
de ses funérailles nationales
à la cathédrale
Saint-Paul de Londres,
le 30 janvier 1965 ?
*Propos en anglais
Il est vrai
qu'ils se sont tant aimés,
ou plutôt admirés, détestés,
réconciliés,
violemment fâchés
à nouveau,
avant de se retrouver
à jamais.
Ils se sont affrontés
en chefs de guerre,
en alliés, en politiciens,
en négociateurs,
en chefs d'Etat, en camarades
de tant de combats, et finalement,
le dernier
mais pas le moindre,
ils se sont affrontés
en écrivains.
De véritables écrivains
mais rivaux,
à l'heure de publier
leurs mémoires de guerre,
et de graver
dans le marbre de la postérité,
chacun à sa façon,
sa propre version
de leur histoire commune.
Musique pesante
...
C'est l'un de ces endroits
devenus historiques
où je ressens comme nulle part
ailleurs la présence des morts.
...
Difficile de pénétrer
dans la Boisserie
de Charles de Gaulle,
sa gentilhommière
de Colombey-les-Deux-Eglises,
dans la Haute-Marne,
sans ressentir
qu'elle est habitée.
Toute sa personnalité
et son caractère transparaissent
ici, dans chacun des meubles,
dans chaque bibelot,
dans chaque gravure,
dans sa bibliothèque,
et dans le choix de conserver
des livres de jeunesse,
ce qui ne peut laisser insensible
l'écrivain en moi.
Un peu plus loin, là,
dans cette table de bridge
sur laquelle
il faisait régulièrement
en fin de journée
des réussites.
"Ma discipline d'oisiveté",
comme disait.
Tout est resté en l'état,
dans sa simplicité même.
Il est mort
à quelques mètres de son bureau,
là où, ivre de son esseulement,
il ne conçoit pas d'écrire
autrement : sa haute silhouette
arc-boutée sur son bureau,
son stylo à encre
glissant sur la rame de papier,
isolé de la rumeur du monde,
sa fenêtre donnant
sur l'âpreté
de la campagne champenoise.
Un écrivain est un solitaire.
Charles de Gaulle n'a pas
à forcer sa nature.
La présence de son ami
Winston Churchill est assurée
par son portrait
trônant parmi les grands
de ce monde,
et surtout par ses mémoires,
à portée
de sa main.
La publication simultanée
de leurs mémoires de guerre,
à la charnière
des années 40 et 50,
a été un événement mondial.
Ils y ont fait oeuvre d'écrivains.
Cela paraît inimaginable
avec le recul,
mais Churchill
a même été couronné
de la récompense suprême :
le prix Nobel de littérature.
Mais des deux,
était-ce le bon lauréat ?
Pour en juger,
il ne faut pas seulement s'arrêter
à leur statut de chefs de guerre,
ce qu'ils ont été sur le front,
mais revenir
aux oeuvres elles-mêmes,
et surtout,
à la dimension humaine
de ces deux écrivains-soldats.
Il faut aussi reconsidérer
ces mémoires de guerre
d'un point de vue littéraire,
en bénéficiant du recul du temps.
70 années
se sont écoulées
depuis la parution de ces livres,
qui ont connu
un succès considérable à l'époque,
et on le sait bien :
on gagne toujours à séparer
les livres du bruit qu'ils font.
Musique nostalgique
...
Pour comprendre pourquoi
leurs mémoires demeurent
un témoignage essentiel,
il faut d'abord traverser
la campagne anglaise,
si chère à Sir Winston,
car la volonté des deux auteurs
de s'inscrire aussi
comme écrivains
dans notre mémoire
nous invite
à les juger aussi comme tels.
Transportons-nous donc
dans ces manuscrits,
là où ceux-ci sont protégés
des regards indiscrets,
à l'égal de documents explosifs :
aux archives entreposées
dans un bâtiment
à l'université de Cambridge.
Un chercheur gagne toujours
à se reporter
aux documents originaux,
même s'il n'a pas affaire
à des manuscrits
mais à des tapuscrits.
La graphie de l'auteur en marge,
son tremblé parfois,
l'importance de ses corrections,
la nature de ses remords,
ses rajouts et ses suppressions :
tout cela compte.
A les lire,
je croirais l'entendre parler.
C'est le cas lorsqu'il évoque
le départ de de Gaulle
pour Londres,
le 17 juin 1940.
Difficile
de ne pas en faire son miel.
Musique grandiose
...
-"Dès que l'appareil
commença à rouler,
"de Gaulle sauta dedans
et claqua la porte.
"L'avion pris son envol,
"tandis que policiers
et fonctionnaires français
"restaient bouche bée.
"Dans ce petit avion,
de Gaulle
"emportait avec lui
l'honneur de la France."
-Lorsqu'il raconte à son tour
le même événement,
de Gaulle est plus sec
et plus lapidaire.
-"Le départ eu lieu sans romantisme
et sans difficulté."
Musique douce
Le moteur de l'avion vrombit.
...
-Pour comprendre un écrivain,
ses manuscrits ne suffisent pas.
Son style littéraire est en harmonie
avec son style de vie.
Il faut se rendre sur ses lieux,
le visiter dans le motif,
comme on le dirait d'un peintre
en pleine nature,
à Chartwell, dans le Kent.
Chant des oiseaux
...
Winston Churchill offre
une tout autre image
de l'écrivain au travail
quand on va chez lui.
...
Il privilégiait, lui aussi,
ses séjours au vert,
dans son domaine plein d'animaux,
un endroit
extrêmement chaleureux
et attachant
aux yeux de tout anglophile,
décor que l'on jurerait
churchillissime.
Musique classique
Après tout, la vie est trop courte
pour être petite.
...
Cette folie, car c'en est une
eu égard au coût de son entretien,
a été en partie financée
par certains de ses amis,
quelques hommes riches et puissants
de son 1er cercle.
Pour l'autre partie,
par les revenus
de ses nombreux écrits,
dans la presse
ou en librairie.
Non qu'il eut la plume facile,
c'est simplement
qu'il était, disons...
organisé.
Son oeuvre a donc été nourrie
par une passion
pour la chose politique
comme chez peu d'écrivains,
ce qui témoigne
qu'être un homme d'action
n'empêche pas de produire.
Oui, mais à quel prix ?
*La foule rit.
Musique énigmatique
-Pour dominer cette bête,
il a sa méthode.
Les six volumes consacrés
à la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
écrits entre 1948 et 1954,
n'y échappent pas.
Tapotis
Il n'écrit pas vraiment,
mais dicte depuis un lieu
pour le moins intime : son lit,
dans lequel on le trouve
assis ou couché,
un cigare dans une main,
un verre de whisky dans l'autre,
papiers et documents étalés
sur sa couverture.
Il y a en permanence
une ou deux secrétaires
à ses côtés,
lesquelles sont
légèrement embarrassées
lorsqu'il dicte
non plus depuis son lit,
mais depuis son étrange baignoire,
la porte grande ouverte.
La surface de l'eau
est couverte de mousse,
mais tout de même :
"shocking !",
ce dont il se fiche royalement,
et même impérialement.
Pour écrire,
Churchill fait appel à des dactylos,
et surtout,
à ses assistants littéraires,
ainsi qu'il nomme ceux
qui sont au fait "ses nègres".
Les biographes ont pu en dresser
une liste de six.
...
Pour prendre la mesure
de son petit consortium,
il faut se rendre
au rez-de-chaussée du manoir,
où les machines à écrire
se font face.
Les collaborateurs
fournissent la base,
la recherche documentaire,
puis ils rédigent
les grandes lignes.
Churchill réécrit l'ensemble,
car le style est l'homme même, soit.
Si l'Anglais est innombrable
lorsqu'il écrit,
le Français, de Gaulle,
dont le portrait
figure dans cette pièce
devenue si symbolique,
lui, est seul.
Cela correspond tellement
à son tempérament.
Musique légère
...
-Si l'on est sensible
au génie des lieux,
alors on peut dire que la Boisserie
à Colombey-les-Deux-Eglises
était faite pour Charles de Gaulle.
De proportions raisonnables,
décorée sans ostentation,
il l'avait acquise à un prix
très sage en 1934. Surtout,
elle est nimbée
d'un passé littéraire,
ce qui n'était pas fait
pour lui déplaire.
Car le détail est peu connu,
mais pendant les 7 années
qui ont précédé
sa présence, les Jolas,
un couple
d'intellectuels américains,
y ont fait souffler le vent
de l'avant-garde
littéraire et artistique
sous la double influence
du romantisme allemand
et du surréalisme.
Ils y habitaient, à Colombey.
Ils y fabriquaient,
à la Boisserie, une revue,
et y publièrent tant de textes
d'Artaud ou de Michaud,
sans oublier le principal,
leur grande fierté, James Joyce.
Reste à savoir si quelque chose
de Joyce a déteint sur de Gaulle,
à supposer que deux génies puissent
cohabiter dans les mêmes lieux.
Stridulations
La solitude
de l'écrivain de Gaulle,
c'est celle d'un individualiste
à l'esprit d'équipe.
A Colombey,
ses assistants se comptent
sur les doigts d'une main,
plutôt des relecteurs,
dont l'écrivain André Malraux.
Ils ont la vertu de décrypter
ses pattes de mouche,
talent qui n'est accordé qu'à ceux
qui ont l'habitude de son écriture.
La mieux à même de l'aider,
c'est encore sa fille,
Elisabeth de Boissieu.
Elle doit taper à la machine
des textes qui sont si surchargés
qu'ils finissent par ressembler
à des tableaux d'Alechinsky.
Tapotis
...
C'est avec un modus operandi
aussi sobre et économe,
entouré d'une équipe
aussi légère, que de Gaulle a écrit
ses mémoires de guerre en solitaire.
...
Stridulations
Son de cloche
...
Il en naît des histoires d'amitié,
comme des histoires d'amour.
On n'oublie jamais
les premières fois.
Généralement,
cela se passe mal.
Si la première rencontre
entre ces deux hommes de caractère
n'échappe pas à la règle,
à la deuxième, cela s'arrange.
Le courant passe,
mais ce n'est pas
forcément
un courant alternatif.
"God Save The Queen"
...
Car si l'Anglais est chaleureux,
le Français a tout
d'un poisson froid, sinon congelé.
-"Monsieur Churchill me reçut
à Downing Street.
"C'était la première fois
que je prenais contact avec lui.
"Il me parut être de plain-pied
avec la tâche la plus rude,
"pourvu qu'elle fut
aussi grandiose.
"Par-dessus tout, il était,
de par son caractère,
"fait pour agir,
risquer, jouer le rôle,
"très carrément,
et sans scrupule.
Musique classique
-"Je vis le général De Gaulle
qui se tenait près de l'entrée,
"immobile et flegmatique.
"En le saluant, je lui dis
à mi-voix en français :
"'L'homme du destin.'
"Il resta impassible.
Sous son attitude imperturbable,
"il me parut avoir une surprenante
sensibilité à la douleur.
"C'est une impression
que j'ai conservée depuis,
"au contact de cet homme
très grand et flegmatique.
"Voici le connétable de France."
...
Musique intrigante
-Leurs styles littéraires diffèrent,
mais au-delà de cette dimension,
tout dans leur personnalité
et leur caractère,
leur mode de vie,
leur style, quoi,
tout les oppose.
L'un, le Français,
est un homme qui marche,
une silhouette sculptée
par Giacometti, haut perché,
toujours en mouvement
vers l'avant
et souvent en tenue
d'officier de charge
juché sur des grandes bottes.
Un héron.
L'autre, c'est une masse,
mais une masse paisible
qui s'applique à respecter
ses deux devises,
celles d'un homme
assis dans un fauteuil.
Il dit souvent :
"Ne jamais rester debout
quand vous pouvez être assis"
et "Ne jamais être assis
"si vous pouvez être couchés."
...
L'Anglais déborde d'émotion,
de vivacité, de sentimentalisme.
Francophile
depuis l'invention du champagne,
il maîtrise bien notre langue.
...
*-C'est moi, Churchill,
qui vous parle.
Pendant plus de 30 ans,
j'ai marché avec vous
et je marche encore avec vous.
Musique grandiose
-Il est adulé par les Anglais,
qui voient en lui un sauveur.
C'est incontestablement son moment,
il lui faut le saisir.
Il a d'autant moins de mal
à endosser l'habit de héros national
qu'il se rêve tel
depuis l'enfance
jusqu'à sa jeunesse
sous les drapeaux.
Il est vrai qu'elles se sont
déroulées dans un décor majestueux.
Musique classique grandiose
...
C'est à Blenheim Palace,
cet univers royal
et impérial,
l'immense château familial,
dont il est sorti
avec la promesse
faite à lui-même
d'être un jour
à la hauteur des siens.
...
Ses jeunes années se déroulèrent
à l'ombre des tableaux
et des tapisseries
des grandes batailles
accrochés aux murs
qu'il reconstituait en disposant
ses soldats de plomb sur le tapis.
...
Ce fut le théâtre de son imaginaire,
là où il se projeta
en digne héritier
de John Churchill,
Ier duc de Marlborough
et chef de guerre.
...
A force de vivre
parmi les souvenirs glorieux
de ses ancêtres, Churchill
s'est naturellement identifié
à leurs figures légendaires
jusqu'à se projeter dans l'avenir
comme le rempart de sa nation.
...
Musique mutine
A la Boisserie,
chez de Gaulle,
la bibliothèque reflète
non seulement
l'esprit et la culture,
mais surtout l'âme
de ce grand lecteur.
Les héros de son enfance
ont été ceux de la nation
et non ceux de la famille.
...
Pour de Gaulle, tout doit passer
par l'écrit et la littérature
dans un lexique, un ton inspirés
du grand siècle d'où sont issus
les Bossuet et les Fénelon
dont les livres ont bercé
son adolescence aux côtés des grands
auteurs des Humanités classiques,
les Romains et les Grecs.
Elle s'est déroulée
dans une famille
de fonctionnaires
et de juristes parisiens,
de sérieux érudits
et des catholiques légitimistes
qui lui ont transmis le goût
des études et du service de l'Etat.
A 15 ans,
il se décrivait déjà
en général De Gaulle
sauvant la France.
Dès lors, nul ne s'étonne,
à l'école militaire de Saint-Cyr,
qu'il n'envisage pas
d'autre carrière
que le service des armes.
...
Churchill non plus,
qui n'imaginait pas un seul instant
faire ses classes
ailleurs qu'à Sandhurst,
le Saint-Cyr anglais...
et c'est bien
leur seul véritable point commun.
...
Musique intense
On a vu des couples
mieux partis dans la vie,
en tout cas,
mieux assortis.
Churchill, qui a
16 ans de plus que lui,
confie à un proche :
"Ce de Gaulle ressemble
à un lama femelle
"surpris dans son bain."
Un jugement profond
qui ne manque pas d'imagination.
L'intéressé
n'est pas en reste.
A la sortie d'une réunion
du cabinet de guerre,
il sourit à la vue
du noeud papillon à pois
qui se détache sur la chemise
à carreaux de l'Anglais
en lui faisant remarquer :
"Tiens, c'est carnaval aujourd'hui",
à quoi le Premier ministre
répond du tac au tac :
"Tout le monde ne peut pas
se déguiser en soldat inconnu."
Il semble que les deux
avaient le sens de l'humour,
mais celui de de Gaulle
était si discret
qu'on le cherche encore.
Pas d'intimité,
pas de tapes dans le dos,
pas de familiarités
avec lui.
Qu'importe, puisqu'ils sont
d'accord sur l'essentiel.
Il est Premier ministre
alors que de Gaulle
n'est qu'un sous-secrétaire d'Etat
à la Défense nationale.
Pourtant, dès son arrivée à Londres,
il le traite déjà en égal
en qualité de chef
des Français libres.
...
-"Naufragé de la désolation
sur les rivages de l'Angleterre...
"qu'aurais-je pu faire
"sans son concours ?
"Il me le donna tout de suite
et mit, pour commencer,
"la BBC à ma disposition."
*Fréquences radio
*-Moi, général De Gaulle,
j'entreprends ici, en Angleterre,
cette tâche nationale
et j'invite
tous les militaires français
des armées de terre,
de mer et de l'air
à se réunir à moi.
-"A mesure que s'envolaient
les mots irrévocables,
"je sentais en moi-même
se terminer une vie,
"celle que j'avais menée
dans le cadre d'une France solide
"et d'une indivisible armée.
"A 49 ans,
j'entrais dans l'aventure
"comme un homme que le destin jetait
hors de toutes les séries."
...
-C'est grâce à Churchill qu'il peut
s'installer au 4, Carlton Gardens,
une prestigieuse résidence
encadrée de colonnes doriques
et de colonnades corinthiennes,
le quartier général
des Forces françaises libres.
Difficile d'imaginer
qu'à son arrivée,
au début de l'été 1940,
il n'était rien, un paria,
un hors-la-loi,
un officier félon sans troupe
ni soutien international,
un homme seul.
*-Vive la France libre
dans l'honneur
et dans l'indépendance...
-Un homme seul, un rebelle dressé
de toute sa violence,
sa colère
et son indignation
contre le maréchal Pétain
et le régime de Vichy.
-"La vieillesse est un naufrage.
Pour que rien ne nous fût épargné,
"la vieillesse
du maréchal Pétain
"allait s'identifier
avec le naufrage de la France."
Musique sombre
...
-Deux semaines après,
à Londres,
les Forces françaises libres
sont créées sur le papier.
De Gaulle est rejoint
par de rares civils
et quelques milliers
de soldats,
des centaines d'officiers,
d'aviateurs, des marins.
En France, on raille ces Forces
en les décrivant
entourées de journalistes juifs,
d'aristocrates
et de pêcheurs de l'île de Sein,
ce qui n'est pas faux non plus,
et pourtant, il est persuadé
d'incarner la France
par lui restaurée
dans son honneur et dans sa dignité.
On dira que s'appeler de Gaulle
prédispose,
même dans un anglais, disons...
assez personnel.
On better order.
-De fait, un jour,
il sera le seul Français
à pouvoir dire en public
"Moi, la France"
sans être aussitôt
transféré à Sainte-Anne.
Churchill supporte difficilement
l'attitude implacable,
irréaliste
d'un de Gaulle habité,
sinon hanté, toute sa vie durant,
par une certaine idée de la France.
Il lui arrive même
de perdre patience
et de s'emporter
auprès de ses collaborateurs.
"Ce type est un dingue !"
-"Nous fîmes néanmoins
"de notre mieux
pour accroître son influence,
"son autorité
et son pouvoir.
"De son côté, il prenait
naturellement fort mal
"toute relation de notre part
avec les gens de Vichy
"et considérait que nous lui devions
une loyauté exclusive.
"Il jugeait également
essentiel
"à sa position
aux yeux du peuple français
"de conserver une attitude
fière et hautaine
"envers la perfide Albion."
-Du latin "perfidia",
qui signifie "mauvaise foi".
Si perfide Albion
que de Gaulle a toujours éprouvé
non pas une certaine
détestation de l'Angleterre,
mais une profonde méfiance
vis-à-vis d'elle.
Ce sentiment est revivifié
début juillet 1940.
Musique intense
...
Les Anglais veulent à tout prix
empêcher le Reich
de s'emparer
des bâtiments de guerre français
stationnés à Mers el-Kébir,
un port d'Algérie.
Après des ultimatums,
la Royal Navy coule
la plus grande partie
de l'escadre française.
-Les beaux navires
sont incendiés
par les obus britanniques.
-Impuissant, de Gaulle
subit son anéantissement,
qu'il finit par justifier
dans ses mémoires.
-"M'adressant aux Français,
je leur demande de considérer
"le fond des choses
du seul point de vue
"qui doit finalement compter,
"c'est-à-dire du point de vue
de la victoire
"et de la délivrance.
Je dis sans ambages
"qu'il veut mieux
que les navires aient été détruits.
"Nos deux vieux peuples,
nos deux grands peuples
"demeurent liés
l'un à l'autre.
"Ils succomberont tous les deux
ou bien il gagneront ensemble."
-"Ce fut une décision odieuse,
la plus inhumaine,
"la plus pénible de toutes celles
auxquelles j'ai été associé.
"C'était une tragédie grecque.
"Pourtant, jamais aucun acte
ne fut plus nécessaire
"à la survie
de l'Angleterre
"et de tous ceux
qui comptaient sur elle."
Musique intense
-Près de 1500 marins
y laissent la vie.
Le nationalisme de de Gaulle,
mis devant le fait accompli,
est très ébranlé
car le sang français a coulé.
Aussi, peu après,
c'est lui qui est à la manoeuvre
pour inciter Churchill
à s'emparer
de la marine française
à Dakar.
Mal préparée, l'opération aboutit
à un douloureux fiasco
qu'ils vivent solidairement
dans la même galère.
Musique triste
...
Lorsqu'il fend l'armure
et se confie à des proches,
le général reconnaît
le coup de blues.
Abattu, il broie du noir,
c'est peu de le dire.
Pour la seule fois de sa vie,
il est hanté
par des pulsions suicidaires.
-"Les jours qui suivirent
me furent cruels.
"J'éprouvais
les impressions d'un homme
"dont un séisme secoue
brutalement la maison
"et qui reçoit
sur la tête
"la pluie des tuiles
tombant du toit."
...
-Churchill, lui, est coutumier
de cet état d'âme.
Sa mélancolie, issue
d'un état dépressif latent,
il l'a domestiquée, même si
elle le fait souffrir par à-coups.
Il l'a surnommée "mon Black dog"
et l'arrivée de ce "chien noir"
s'annonce à chaque fois
par un grand coup
qui s'abat sur sa nuque
et qu'il surmonte
en se noyant dans l'alcool
plus encore
qu'à l'accoutumée.
Mais ce qui s'abat
sur la nuque de son peuple,
c'est un déluge
de feu et d'acier
lancé à partir du 7 septembre 1940
par la Luftwaffe.
Huit mois durant, ce "Blitz",
"l'éclair" en allemand,
pousse les habitants
à se terrer dans les caves,
les abris, le métro londonien
à plus de 50 m de profondeur.
Un bébé pleure.
Musique sombre
Pour prendre la mesure
de cet enfermement,
il faut se rendre
là où s'enterrait
le cabinet de guerre
dirigé par Churchill.
Son bunker secret est situé
en plein centre de la capitale.
...
Il abrite
de nombreuses pièces
dans un labyrinthe de galeries
conservées à l'identique.
...
-Voici le bruit
qui fit partie intégrante
de la vie de chaque homme,
de chaque femme
et de chaque enfant
d'Angleterre.
Alerte
...
-Churchill y a rarement vécu
avec sa femme, ses ministres
et les officiers
de son staff.
Il y a parfois participé
à des réunions stratégiques
sur la conduite de la guerre
et l'organisation des batailles.
...
Des téléphones sonnent.
Tic-tac d'horloge
...
La présence
de cartes géographiques
qui tapissent toutes les pièces,
les salles de réunion
comme les chambres,
en témoigne.
...
C'est dans cette atmosphère
oppressante car enterrée
que Churchill a passé une partie
de son temps, jour et nuit,
à réfléchir à huis clos,
à dormir, à décider
et surtout
à encourager son peuple
au micro de la BBC
installé à cet effet.
-La manière dont il évoque
ces moments-là dans ses mémoires
rappelle son talent
de journaliste,
activité dans laquelle
il a longtemps exercé sa plume
avant de se jeter
dans la carrière littéraire.
-"Les raids de nuit
s'accompagnaient d'attaques de jour
"plus ou moins continuelles,
menées par de petites
"formations ennemies
ou même par des appareils isolés
"et souvent,
les sirènes retentissaient
"à de brèves intervalles
"tout au long des 24 heures
d'une journée.
"Les 7 millions d'habitants
de Londres
"finirent par s'accoutumer
à cette étrange existence."
Musique pesante
...
-Au fond, si hauts que soient
le Premier ministre britannique
et le chef de la France libre,
ne relèvent-ils pas eux aussi
de cette foule qui redresse la tête
dès le lendemain
des bombardements de Londres
et de Coventry ?
Une foule que Churchill
évoque comme
"des gens ordinaires confrontés
à une époque extraordinaire."
Musique douce
...
-Une formule winstonissime
que de Gaulle
reprendra à son compte.
-Jamais tant d'hommes sur la terre
n'ont tant attendu de nous.
Musique intense
-Je les imagine bien
l'un et l'autre,
Churchill et de Gaulle,
touchés par cette photographie
accrochée à un mur
de mon bureau.
Cette image est l'une
des plus iconiques du Blitz :
la bibliothèque
de Holland House, à Londres,
dévastée par des bombes larguées
par l'aviation allemande
sur ce quartier de l'ouest.
Des personnages
y cherchent un livre
dans des rayonnages en ruines
comme si de rien n'était.
Musique émouvante
Il y a là
quelque chose de surréel
qui reflète bien
la folie de l'époque
et l'absurdité d'une guerre
si dévastatrice.
Piano doux
Les bibliothèques
ont pour vocation
de conserver, protéger
et communiquer les livres,
non d'être le spectacle morbide
de leur destruction.
...
Les livres,
nos deux hommes de guerre
ont toujours vécu
dans et par eux.
...
Les manuscrits des mémoires
de guerre du général
ont été
naturellement accueillis
par la Bibliothèque nationale
à Paris.
Les consulter
relève d'un cérémonial
qui est en partie lié
avec le sacré.
...
Ces pages originales
ne s'y laissent découvrir
que sur dérogation
et avec 1000 précautions,
à commencer par l'usage exclusif
du crayon à mine
pour prendre des notes.
Surtout pas d'encre,
de crainte d'un accident.
Sous la plume
de de Gaulle,
une écriture, la sienne,
nerveuse, tordue, surchargée,
pleine de ratures,
et donc de remords,
ce qui reflète, au fond,
sa recherche obsessionnelle
du mot juste. Il correspond
à la définition qu'Oscar Wilde
donnait d'un écrivain :
"Quelqu'un qui passe sa matinée
à rajouter une virgule
"et son après-midi
"à la retirer."
...
Il est intéressant de comparer
l'état de leurs manuscrits.
Avec Churchill, il s'agit
d'un "tapuscrit", puisqu'il dicte,
mais jusqu'à la fin,
pour ne pas déplaire
aux uns et aux autres
et se conformer
à leurs désirs,
c'est plein de mots barrés
et remplacés par d'autres
afin de ne vexer personne,
à commencer par de Gaulle.
Ainsi a-t-il éliminé
les passages
où il le traite de, je cite,
"Fuhrer en germe",
donc des mots barrés
à l'aide
d'un crayon à mine bleu,
dedans, un autre type de tableau,
ce que le pastelliste en lui,
passionné par toutes les nuances
de bleu, n'aurait pas renié.
...
La grande qualité
de Churchill,
qui fait pour l'instant défaut
à de Gaulle,
c'est que dès qu'il parle en public,
il le met dans sa poche.
Paradoxalement, c'est là
que le styliste se révèle en lui
car sa grande oeuvre,
ce sont ses discours,
ce qui ne va pas de soi
pour un homme affecté
d'un défaut de prononciation,
un zézaiement.
*Whatever the cost,
we shall never surrender.
-Des qualités oratoires
que de Gaulle
reconnaît lui envier.
-"Quel que fut son auditoire,
"qu'il se trouva
devant un micro, à la tribune,
"à table
ou derrière un bureau,
"le flot original, poétique,
émouvant de ses idées,
"arguments, sentiments,
lui procurait un ascendant
"presque infaillible
dans l'ambiance dramatique
"où haletait le pauvre monde."
-Ce monde tourne vraiment
sur ses gonds
lorsque les Etats-Unis entrent
en guerre, en décembre 1941.
Malgré l'admiration
que de Gaulle voue à Churchill,
leur relation connaît à nouveau
une période de glaciation
avec l'arrivée d'un troisième homme
qui s'impose alors entre eux
de toute sa puissance :
le président Franklin Roosevelt.
Churchill,
proche de lui pour des raisons
tant historiques que personnelles,
sa propre mère était américaine,
se rapproche davantage encore.
Un pas de deux
qui exclue le Français.
L'important est que Roosevelt
est désormais le leadership
du monde libre.
*Musique triomphante
-La détestation de Roosevelt
pour de Gaulle est notoire.
Il voit en lui
un apprenti dictateur.
Non seulement il le méprise
mais il tente d'y entraîner
Churchill qui se retrouve écartelé
entre deux fidélités.
Roosevelt et Churchill ont un plan
pour mener l'offensive
depuis l'Afrique du Nord
mais ils ne souhaitent pas
y associer de Gaulle.
-"Si nous avions mêlé
"de Gaulle à l'affaire, cela aurait
produit le plus fâcheux effet
"sur les réactions des Français
d'Afrique du Nord.
"Pourtant il fallait
manifestement trouver
"quelques hautes personnalités
françaises,
"et aux yeux des Britanniques
et des Américains,
"nul ne semblait plus qualifié
que le général Giraud."
-Le général Giraud est plus souple,
plus accommodant
et tellement plus chaleureux
que l'insupportable de Gaulle.
Il est le pion idéal
pour les Américains
et un rival de taille
pour de Gaulle,
désormais sur la touche.
-"Nous parlâmes de Roosevelt
"et de son attitude à mon égard.
"'Ne brusquez rien',
dit monsieur Churchill.
"Voyez comment, tour à tour,
je plie et me relève.
"'Vous le pouvez', observais-je,
parce que vous êtes assis
"sur un Etat solide, une nation
rassemblée, un empire uni,
"de grandes armées,
mais moi, où sont mes moyens ?"
"Pourtant j'ai, vous le savez,
la charge des intérêts
"et du destin de la France.
"C'est trop lourd
et je suis trop pauvre
"pour que je puisse me courber.
"Monsieur Churchill conclut
notre entretien
"par une démonstration
d'amitié et d'émotion.
"'Nous avons encore
de rudes obstacles à surmonter.
"'Mais un jour,
nous serons en France,
"'peut-être l'année prochaine,
en tout cas,
"'nous y serons ensemble.
Je ne vous lâcherai pas.'"
Musique sombre
...
-Et pourtant Churchill organise
une opération d'envergure
avec le président américain.
Une ligne transatlantique
permet même
au Premier ministre britannique
de s'entretenir
à tout instant avec lui.
Leurs états-majors
ourdissent en secret
l'opération Torch,
un débarquement de troupes alliées
en Afrique du Nord
en novembre 1942 et de Gaulle
est exclu de tous ses préparatifs.
Musique grave
-"J'avais conscience des liens
qui nous unissaient à de Gaulle
"et de la gravité de l'affront
que nous allions lui infliger
"en le tenant délibérément à l'écart
"de toute participation
à l'entreprise.
"J'avais l'intention de l'informer
"juste avant
que le coup ne fut porté."
...
Musique patriotique
Tirs
...
-Ce débarquement mené
sur les plages d'Algérie et du Maroc
permet aux Alliés de prendre pied
sur le sol africain.
...
C'est leur première grande victoire
militaire et de Gaulle n'en est pas.
C'est aussi que Roosevelt
a son homme,
il n'en démord pas :
le général Giraud,
qu'il tient à installer
à la tête de l'armée d'Afrique.
...
Musique mystérieuse
De toute évidence,
l'orgueil de de Gaulle
est agressé au plus haut
par ses alliés.
-"Monsieur Churchill
s'en prit alors à moi
"sur un ton acerbe et passionné.
Il s'écria avec fureur :
"'Vous dites
que vous êtes la France.
"'Vous n'êtes pas la France.
"'Je ne vous reconnais pas
comme la France.'
"Puis toujours véhément :
'La France, où est-elle ?'"
-Comment n'en concevrait-il pas
une humiliation
d'autant plus cruelle
que la conférence d'Anfa
se déroule en janvier 1943
devant les caméras internationales.
-Roosevelt et Churchill y préparent
déjà leur stratégie
pour l'après-guerre.
Manifestant sa colère froide
face à son exclusion,
donc celle de la France,
de Gaulle arrive en retard,
allant même jusqu'à les faire
attendre deux jours.
-"De Gaulle arriva enfin
le 22 janvier.
"Il fut conduit à sa villa qui était
voisine de celle de Giraud.
"Il refusa d'aller visiter
"ce dernier et il fallut
plusieurs heures d'effort
"pour le décider à changer d'avis.
"J'eus un entretien glacial
avec de Gaulle
"et lui fis clairement comprendre
que nous n'hésiterions pas
"à rompre définitivement avec lui
"s'il persistait
dans son opposition."
Musique intrigante
-"Le Premier ministre m'adressa
des reproches amers
"où je ne pus voir autre chose
que l'alibi de l'embarras.
"Il m'annonça
qu'en rentrant à Londres,
"il m'accuserait publiquement
d'avoir empêché l'entente,
"dresserait contre ma personne
l'opinion de son pays
"et en appellerait
à celle de la France.
"De toute la guerre, ce fut
la plus rude de nos rencontres."
-De Gaulle se résout finalement
à s'asseoir
à la table des négociations
pour être agréable à Churchill
qui aura beaucoup insisté.
Un moment historique
totalement fabriqué.
Il dira même à Roosevelt :
"I shall do that for you."
Autrement dit : "Si je le fais,
c'est bien pour vous."
Propos en anglais
-Roosevelt le pousse
à faire une seconde prise
pour la bonne cause.
-De Gaulle, qui sort du cadre,
dirige désormais,
conjointement
avec le général Giraud,
les forces françaises en guerre.
Musique entraînante
-"Monsieur Churchill,
"chaque fois
que nous nous heurtions,
"en raison des intérêts
dont nous avions respectivement
"la charge,
faisait de notre désaccord
"comme une affaire personnelle.
Il en était blessé et chagriné,
"à proportion de l'amitié
qui nous liait l'un à l'autre.
"Ses dispositions
de l'esprit et du sentiment,
"jointes aux recettes
de sa tactique politique,
"le jetaient
dans des crises de colère
"qui secouaient rudement
nos rapports."
-Ce que veulent les Anglo-Saxons,
c'est rien moins
que la mise sous tutelle américaine
de la France, ce qui est,
aux yeux de de Gaulle, inacceptable,
inenvisageable et non négociable.
Des téléphones sonnent.
On comprend dès lors que de Gaulle
subisse un troisième affront :
il est exclu
des préparatifs du jour J,
le débarquement en Normandie,
le 6 juin 1944.
Musique grandiose
...
-A 6h30,
les premières troupes d'assaut
et les chars des Alliés
débarquent sur les plages normandes.
...
Au même moment,
celui que l'on surnomme
le général Micro en est réduit
à user de la BBC, cette fois,
pour sauver l'honneur
et assurer la présence
de la France libre et de son chef
en ce jour historique.
-"Après tant de combats,
de fureur, de douleur,
"voici venu le choc décisif.
"C'est la bataille de France
"et c'est la bataille
que la France..."
-La circonstance le pousse
à être plus lyrique
qu'à l'accoutumée
en adoptant une fois de plus
des accents churchilliens.
-"Derrière le nuage si lourd
de notre sang et de nos larmes,
"voici que reparaît
"le soleil de notre grandeur."
-De Gaulle, lui,
a débarqué en Normandie
6 jours après les autres.
Il n'a qu'une idée en tête :
libérer Paris.
Pour les Alliés,
c'est un objectif secondaire.
Ils veulent même
contourner la capitale.
Mais de Gaulle n'en démord pas
et il faut que ce soit des Français,
ceux de la deuxième division blindée
du général Leclerc,
qui entrent les premiers dans Paris
et que ce soit lui,
le général De Gaulle,
qui incarne la libération
la plus symbolique
au regard de la postérité.
Une exigence de plus
qui agace son allié Churchill.
-"Ce type, de Gaulle,
est insupportable
"et c'est lui qui a raison.
La France, la seule France,
"la France libre,
c'est lui et nul autre.
"Dans l'avenir, ce sera lui,
aussi vrai que moi, Churchill,
"je serai celui de l'Angleterre."
Musique douce
...
-Le 25 août 1944,
le général De Gaulle
entre dans Paris en vainqueur,
mais jusqu'à la fin de sa vie,
il boycottera
les commémorations
du jour le plus long.
...
-"Je ranime la flamme.
"Depuis le 14 juin 1940,
"nul n'avait pu le faire
qu'en présence de l'envahisseur.
"Puis je quitte la voûte
et le terre-plein.
"Les assistances s'écartent.
"Devant moi, les Champs-Elysées.
Musique haletante
*Acclamations
"Ah, c'est la mer !
"Une foule immense est massée
de part et d'autre de la chaussée,
"peut-être deux millions d'âmes.
...
*...
"Nous aurons ainsi, tous ensemble,
bouleversés, fraternels,
"sentant la joie, la fierté,
l'espérance nationale,
"remonté du fond des abîmes.
...
"Il s'agit aujourd'hui
de rendre à lui-même,
"par le spectacle de sa joie
et l'évidence de sa liberté,
"un peuple qui fut hier
écrasé par la défaite
"et dispersé par la servitude."
...
-De toutes les images du général
prises ou filmées pendant la guerre,
c'est la première fois qu'on le voit
enfin le sourire aux lèvres.
...
"God Save The Queen"
Lorsqu'il accueillera
le Premier ministre anglais
deux mois plus tard,
c'est bien de son ami Churchill
qu'il s'agira à nouveau,
l'un comme l'autre,
au faîte de leur gloire.
-"De Gaulle me reçut
à un grand déjeuner,
"au ministère de la Guerre,
et prononça des paroles
"extrêmement flatteuses au sujet
de mon rôle durant le conflit.
"Je fus frappé par le respect,
voire la crainte,
"qu'une demi-douzaine de généraux
de haut grade
"témoignaient à de Gaulle,
"bien qu'il n'eût qu'une étoile
sur son uniforme."
Musique intense
-Les deux chefs de guerre
se retrouvent face à face
pour l'éternité en bas
des Champs-Elysées.
Le sculpteur les a incarnés
en hommes qui marchent.
Ils sont l'histoire mais se dirigent
toujours vers l'avant.
...
Dès la fin de la guerre,
ils continuent à dominer
le paysage politique.
...
Le 13 novembre 1945,
de Gaulle est élu président
du gouvernement provisoire.
...
Mais Churchill, lui,
tombe de son socle :
il est balayé aux élections
par un raz-de-marée travailliste.
...
Désenchanté, il se met au vert
dans son domaine de Chatsworth,
en retrait, pour y écrire
ses mémoires de guerre.
Fidèle à sa promesse
d'être l'historien
d'une épopée
dont il avait été
également le héros,
il produit avec son équipe
six tomes,
dont le premier
paraît en 1948.
...
Churchill devient
un auteur à succès
car les ventes de son oeuvre
sont considérables
et durables,
tant aux Etats-Unis
qu'en Angleterre.
A la librairie Hatchards à Londres,
il est même le seul à bénéficier
de tout un pan de bibliothèque
dédié à ses propres livres,
ainsi qu'à tous ceux,
nombreux,
qui lui ont été consacrés
à ce jour.
Piaillements d'oiseaux
...
Pendant ce temps,
le général De Gaulle,
qui a quitté le pouvoir
et qui entame lui aussi
une traversée du désert,
commence à peine à écrire
ses propres mémoires de guerre
loin de la rumeur du monde.
-"Dans le tumulte des hommes
et des événements,
"la solitude était ma tentation.
"Maintenant, elle est mon amie.
Musique douce
"De quelle autre se contenter
quand on a rencontré l'histoire ?"
-Avec ses souvenirs
de la France libre,
qui ont la force du témoignage,
de Gaulle quitte le statut
d'écrivain militaire, qu'il avait
acquis dans les années 30,
pour celui d'écrivain d'histoire.
Un écrivain
ne comprend ce qui lui arrive
que lorsqu'il l'écrit.
De Gaulle a l'ambition d'édifier
une oeuvre et de se démarquer ainsi
de Churchill, qui selon lui,
s'est contenté de,
je cite,
"mettre beaucoup de choses
bout à bout".
*Musique grandiose
-Pourtant, Winston Churchill
est celui des deux
que l'Académie suédoise
a choisi de consacrer
en 1953 par le prix Nobel
de littérature.
-Le comble,
c'est que l'élu ne dissimule pas
sa déception.
Churchill ne prend même pas
la peine de se déplacer
jusqu'à Stockholm
et y envoie sa femme.
Musique intense
-Il ne fait guère de doute
à l'époque que cette année-là,
la récompense est moins motivée
par des préoccupations littéraires
que par un souci politique
et diplomatique.
En fait,
Sir Winston espérait
le prix Nobel de la paix,
qui ira finalement
à Albert Schweitzer,
qui le moque en privé.
Mais il se résigne
à accepter son Nobel
lorsqu'il apprend que le chèque
est d'un montant
de 12 000 livres sterling,
non imposables.
...
Quant à de Gaulle, la parution
de ses mémoires de guerre
un an plus tard chez Plon,
éditeur choisi
parce qu'il avait été
celui des grands, comme Foch,
a un grand retentissement
dans les mondes politique
et littéraire
dans de nombreux pays.
...
Musique intrigante
Désormais inscrit
aux plus prestigieux
des palmarès littéraires,
Churchill a tout de même
été sacré écrivain
entre François Mauriac
et Ernest Hemingway,
excusez du peu.
...
Or, l'Académie suédoise est censée
distinguer un écrivain
et non un polygraphe doué,
féru d'histoire et assisté
par un atelier de nègres.
Lorsqu'on les relit
avec le recul du temps,
Charles de Gaulle
est bien des deux
l'écrivain.
Un classique dont l'esprit
est gouverné
par un absolu de la langue française
et donc de l'écriture.
Toute sa vie, il s'était fait
une certaine idée de la France,
à travers la littérature,
qui l'avait formé à jamais.
Qu'importe au fond,
puisque ce qui en reste,
c'est l'histoire
d'une amitié contrariée
car passionnée entre deux hommes
que liait une admiration réciproque,
deux monstres sacrés
aux destins façonnés
par la houle de l'histoire.
...
-"Je savais qu'il n'était pas ami
de l'Angleterre,
"mais j'ai toujours retrouvé
en lui l'esprit
"et les conceptions
que le mot 'France'
"évoquera éternellement
tout au long des pages
"de l'histoire."
...
-"Les incidents rudes et pénibles
qui se produisirent
"à maintes reprises entre nous
en raison des frictions
"de nos deux caractères
ont influé sur mon attitude
"à l'égard du Premier ministre
mais non point sur mon jugement.
"Winston Churchill m'a paru,
d'un bout à l'autre du drame,
"comme le grand champion
d'une grande entreprise,
"et le grand artiste
d'une grande histoire."
...
Musique douce
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA